[Music]
the wicked couture look in descendants -
is edgy and chic but wouldn't it be fun
to take it a step further and see what
would happen if their looks were updated
to reflect present fashion trends take a
look we saved the best one for last new
to the things channel then make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss a thing and
click the thumbs up button if you like
this video now here's a peek at how the
cast of dissonance 2 should have looked
the Evil Queen Snow White's time period
has been pinpointed as taking place in
the 16th century Germany HBO production
designer Claire Hummel created a
stunning illustration of what Snow White
would have looked like if Disney had
stayed true to the time period of the
story
Claire added embroidery long sleeves and
head wear instead the Evil Queen sleeves
are long angled and wide the length of
her dress is pretty accurate but it
doesn't have pleats which were common in
that time period but how would the Evil
Queen and snow white look if their
costumes were updated to the present
time fashion illustrator and designer
Hayden Williams brought their look into
the 21st century with this incredible
illustration he gave the Evil Queen
fishnet stockings the shorter skirt and
half shawl on Snow White are modern and
chic Williams really modernized the Evil
Queen's look while staying true to the
signature crown Cape and red rubies for
which we all know her for this is
definitely how the Evil Queen should
have looked for the modern-day
descendants movies don't you think
Evie Evie's costume was designed with
the same blue from her mother's costume
signature ruby red heart details and
gold accents the costume designer Kara
saw an updated Evie's look by adding
leather with a ton of zippers gold
jeweled boots and distressed leggings
this is a pretty big departure from her
mother's 16th century German style can
you picture Evie in old German head
where the long blue hair is definitely a
better choice
Evie did rock and off-the-shoulder
full-length dress at the cotillion and
it was gorgeous she kept a touch of
leather with her red gloves showing that
you can take the girl out of the aisle
but you can't take the aisle out of the
girl we found some of the original
sketches from descendants costume
designer Karis on one of the sketches
shows Evie in a look that never made
to the film and we think it should have
we love the short Cape that comes
together in the back to join a heart
with the crown on top this evilicious
outfit should have been made into this
villain skid wardrobe without a doubts
Cruella De Vil in Disney's animated
movie 101 Dalmatians karela De Vil says
she worships furs it's hard to talk
fashion without discussing karela's love
for her fur coats her story takes place
in the late 1950s early 1960s we checked
it out and big fluffy fur coats were a
total thing back in that time period
what we didn't find any pictures up for
the two-toned black and white hair which
is kind of karelis thing but what a
Carabas look was updated to today's
fashions vogue russia has your answer in
these fabulous fashion pics karela is
drop-dead gorgeous in modern day black
and white fur pieces fierce red strappy
heels high slit skirts leather pants
long white locks with a black streak and
a viciously long cigarette holder this
lookin sleigh puppies as well as fashion
fans all day
seriously we know she hates puppies but
we can't help but love this look the
actress and descendants could totally
pull this off and look amazing Carlos
sweet adorable Carlos is a fashion chip
off the old block
he's got black hair with white frosted
tips a black white and leather red
jacket and even a fur tailed clipped to
his belt even though his mom raised him
to be terrified of dogs he finds out she
was wrong and ends up with a talking dog
as his loyal companion in descendants -
Carlos ends up with a more polished look
at the cotillion
it seems he got rid of the fur by the
end of the film - but we poked around on
the internet and found an amazing work
of art by Sookie Meacham who reimagined
famous Disney characters by swapping the
genders of princesses and villains and
Chan series she reimagined Cruella
Deville
as a rich spoiled but devastatingly
handsome guy we started to wonder if
this sharp dressed socialite with a
sinister flair for fashion would have
been a better look for Carlos it's a
more dangerous and edgy take on the
costume but would have made Carlos's
journey from evil to good a lot more
rewarding to watch not to mention this
hot bad-boy look would be enough to make
Taylor Swift come
from miles away Jafar Jafar is known as
the Royal vizier of Agrabah now opinions
of the time period for the story of
Aladdin varies one artist who goes by
the handle Wickfield
depicted Jafar and what she claims to be
a historically accurate version of the
animated character in wickfield's fan
art she was able to make Jafar into an
intense very serious nobleman with a
parrot and a Cobra staff this guy looks
a lot more intimidating than than too
far in the distance films while this
could be more historically accurate we
couldn't help but wonder what would
happen if we updated too far look puing
86 on deviant art did it for us this
version of Jafar definitely elevates his
game he would be much more persuasive
with this subtle polished look don't you
think if he's living in the modern world
he should really ditch the robe and
upgrade to a sharp blazer and some
skinny jeans
seriously we know the villains are
trapped on the Isle but they don't have
to stay trapped in the 9th or 13th
century right Jay this brings us to
Jafar son Jay okay we are just realizing
how much leather the villain kids wear
it's probably a way to capture the
edginess from the Isle and set them
apart from the kids at auradon prep but
what if jade rests a little differently
you know with less leather and more free
flowing fabric we are loving this look
put together by fashion illustrator
Darren J we know this is a drawing of
aladdin and Jasmine but we love the
updated look and thought the costume
designer for descendants too could use
it for inspiration Jay wears deep red
and gold colors in his wardrobe his look
is stylish and pretty modern but what if
he gave in to his evil side and became
more like his dad then he may wind up
looking more like this illustration pens
by Ayesha Islam it would be a bit more
difficult to fence in these clothes but
he would totally stand out at the
cotillion and this ensemble come to
think of it he's cool in what he's
wearing we wonder if there will be as
much leather in descendants three Ursula
technically all we've seen of Ursula is
one angry tentacle but we hope we are
going to see more of her in descendants
three in The Little Mermaid
Ursula is an intimidating sea witch who
stole Ariel's voice to try to take over
the kingdom she
known for her white hair black tentacles
and turquoise eyeshadow an artist who
goes by Chiara
on deviantART created a piece that was
more historically accurate to the time
in which the Little Mermaid is set in
her amazing creation she showed Ursula
in her human form you can see the
glowing sea shell which contains Ariel's
voice tied around her waist the dress
she is wearing is more indicative of the
period which is referred to as the waist
and extravagance period so what can we
expect Ursula to look like if she
appears in descendants 3 we look to
Hayden Williams again to get his take he
turned the sea witch into a sea goddess
in his illustrations also we are going
crazy for the look that fashion
illustrator Armand m'hidi came up with
those conch shell earrings are fabulous
uma with all this speculation about
Ursula we thought it's best to check out
Yuma's outfit costume designer Khorasan
said she had a lot of fun creating uma
and her crews look she said director
kini Ortega wanted Ulla to look like she
had been dragged on the bottom of the
ocean floor Lumas got enough trinkets on
her to make Ariel go back to full
hoarding mode for those gadgets and
gizmos of plenty Cara took the detail of
Ursula's turquoise eyeshadow and used it
as inspiration for umas look the result
is a wicked cool turquoise braids that
are reminiscent of her mom's tentacles
will admit uma cleans up nice for the
cotillion a little too nice she's the
villain of the story we would have loved
to see her in something like this
artist's version of a sea witch mando
776 captioned this piece saying this was
his version of the Broadway version of
Ursula the sea witch
if Ursula comes back in descendents 3
she should look like this and who I
should take all the fashion lessons she
can get from her stylish mama Maleficent
maleficents costume is so good many have
tried to duplicate it she may be the
most famous Disney villain of all time
her costume is pretty accurate for the
time period of Sleeping Beauty fashion
illustrator Claire Hummel illustrated
this version of maleficents look to more
accurately reflects her time periods she
said who balloons and horn Tenon's are
all the rage during the early to
1400s who blends our outer garments with
long full bodies in flaring sleeves but
what if Maleficent decided to take a
ride into the 21st century Armond
machinery Illustrated modern-day
Maleficent in this mermaid cut dress
keeping the pointy shoulders and collar
hayden williams also put her in a
mermaid tail dress with sharp edges he
updated her hair to look like the horned
Henin and let it flow down her back if
Maleficent wants a famous dizzy Tremaine
makeover she should bring this picture
with her for inspiration that would turn
her into one hot villain mama
how could mal resist an evil mother as
cool as this one mal mal looks great no
matter what she's wearing but we saw a
pretty big departure from the cute
purple Bob to the stylish bangs her
purple and green costume is everything
but if her mom updates her style mal
should too so how could we possibly
improve this look can you imagine mal
with horns like her mom we feel like all
the leather is a bit overkill if mal
wanted to go a bit softer she could rock
some steampunk Couture in the next
villain kid's party all we know is for
the last two movies Mau has been finding
herself so if the third movie is
anything like the first two mouths going
to need a new look maybe when she finds
out who her dad is his look will have an
influence on her style from fans
speculations on who her dad is
she could have style influences from
Hades more do or even Smee from Peter
Pan let's hope she doesn't lets me
influence her fashion sense too much and
that's how the cast of descendants 2
should have looked we'll see you next
time on the things thanks for watching
[Music]